.
SOMEONE MIGHT WANT TO REMIND
KAMALA THAT TWITTER IS AS OF NO
UNDER NEW LEADERSHIP.
JOINING US NOW IS KELLY AND
CONWAY AND JASON SHEA FITS
FREIGHT I WANT TO SAY IT IS
STAGGERING TO HEAR THAT, BUT
THEIR DEFENSE IS OF COURSE THEY
SHOULD BE DOING THAT, THAT IS
THE DEFENSE, OF COURSE THEY
SHOULD BE DIRECTING PRIVATE
COMPANIES TO TAKE ON THIS
INFORMATION IN DEFENSE OF
DEMOCRACY, DO WE EXPECT ANY
OTHER DEFENSE FROM THEM?
BECAUSE SHE HAS VERY LITTLE
CREDIBILITY AND ALMOST ANYTHING
PERIGEE HAD SOME TO HANDLE THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AS OF MAY 2022,
THEY BASICALLY GAVE UP ON THAT,
NO MORE DAY TRIPS TO CENTRAL
AMERICA, NO MORE VISITS, SHE IN
BETWEEN SHE AND BIDEN THEY HAVE
VISITED THE BORDER A GRAND TOTA
OF ONE TIME.
HE HAS BEEN TO DELAWARE 174 DAY
OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
I THINK HER REACTION TO WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH TWITTER IS TYPICA
UP HERE IS SOMEONE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TECH CENTRAL, SHE WA
A UNITED STATES SENATOR IN IS
NOW THE VICE PRESIDENT AND SHE
IS SO REACTIVE.
INSTEAD OF TALKING ABOUT A FREE
FORUM AND INSTEAD OF TALKING
ABOUT WHAT ELON MUSK IS TRYING
TO DO, WHAT OTHER TECH COMPANIE
COULD BE DOING TO MAKE SURE THA
WE THE CITIZENRY DON'T FEEL
SHADOW BANNED OR CENSORED.
TO CONTROL CONTENT, ESPECIALLY
SO CLOSE TO AN ELECTION.
I JUST WANT TO SP1 NK AND KT P
WOULD SAY, I WANT TO CIRCLE BAC
FOR A SECOND THIS WHITE HOUSE O
THE BORDER IS LYING TO US EVERY
SINGLE DAY TO FILE GET THE
POLLING, LYING TO US THAT THE
BORDER IS CLOSED, IT'S NOT OPEN
AND THE MAJORITY OF THE AMERICA
SAY THE BIDEN POLICIES HAVE
OPENED THE BORDER, THEY HOLD
THEM RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND SO NOT ONLY IS SHE
LYING, BUT SHE'S BASICALLY
SAYING TO MORE THAN HALF THE
COUNTRY YOU'RE EITHER BEING
DISHONEST OR MISLED.
IT IS NOT COMPASSIONATE TO ALLO
3 MILLION PEOPLE HERE, THERE AR
17 STATES IN OUR NATION RIGHT
NOW THAT HAVE A POPULATION OF
LESS THAN 3 MILLION IT IS NOT
COMPASSIONATE TO HAVE PEOPLE
SLEEPING IN 33-DEGREE WEATHER
HAVING TEN AND 12 -YEAR-OLDS
MAKING THAT CROSSING THEMSELVES.
I KNOW WHAT HAPPENS TO MANY OF
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE AND SO WHAT
IS HAPPENING WITH THE FENTANYL
AND EVERYTHING YOU'VE SAID IS S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
TO REALIZE THAT EVEN IN THESE
BLUE CITIES GAVIN NEWSOM, EL
PASO'S DEMOCRATIC MAY HEAR, EVE
ARIZONA'S GOVERNOR ELECT.
ERIC ADAMS, THE GOVERNOR OF NEW
YORK CITY SAYING THAT THEY ARE
WRITTEN THESE PLACING THE
HOMELESS IN NEW YORK CITY.
IT HASN'T REALLY HAPPENED SO FAR
.
AND, WHEN IT COMES TO TWITTER.
TO HEAR KAMALA HARRIS AT LEAST
ASKED ABOUT THE TWITTER FILES
WHICH THE MEDIA HAS TOTALLY
IGNORED, BUT WHEN SHE HER ANSWE
WAS THE REVEALING UNDERBELLY OF
THE MODERN LEFT WHICH IS YES,
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE SHOULD B
DOING CENSORING PEOPLE WHO WE
DON'T THINK ARE TELLING OUR SID
OF THE STORY.
WE ARE A CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC
, AND SHE WANTS HER WAY.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE MASSES
WITHOUT THE REPUBLICANS OR
CONSERVATIVES OR ANY DISSENTING
VOICE TO QUESTION THEIR
AUTHORITY.
THAT'S THE WAY THEY HAVE
OPERATED, THAT IS WHY WE HAVE 8
FBI AGENTS NOT WORKING ON
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE, NOT WORKIN
ON CHINA, NOT WORRIED ABOUT
RUSSIA, BUT WORRIED ABOUT THE
SLAYINGS IN IDAHO, NO, THEY ARE
WORKING ON MAKING SURE THAT THI
ADMINISTRATION IS HAS A FULL
FETTER OF JUST OPEN LANE TO DO
WHAT THEY SEE FIT, AND I'VE GOT
TO TELL YOU A PRESIDENT THAT
MUMBLES IN A VICE PRESIDENT WHO
IS REALLY GOOD AT THE WORD
SALADS YOU DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING AND THEN YO
HAVE A WHITE HOUSE SPOKESPERSON
WHO GOES OUT THERE AND SHE JUST
READS AND DOESN'T EVEN ACTUALLY
TELL THE TRUTH, SO IT'S REALLY
HARD TO DECIPHER.
>> I AM INTRIGUED ON THE
POLITICAL SIDE ABOUT WHAT YOU
SAID, DO YOU INCHES OF PATE SOM
DEMOCRATS WILL SEE THE OBVIOUS
IN FRONT OF THEM TURNING FROM
MAY BE PRESIDENTIAL AMBITIONS,
TRULY TURNING AGAINST THE WHITE
HOUSE ON THIS AND SAYING OUR
BORDER IS OUT OF CONTROL?
DO YOU SEE THAT?
>> MAY BE IT STARTS WITH
SENATORS LIKE KIERSTEN CINEMA
AND MAY BE MARK KELLY WILL FIND
THAT MOXIE TO SPEAK UP RIGHT
PEOPLE LIKE THAT, YOU KNOW
87,000 IRS AGENTS AND DOESN'T
REALLY FEEL LIKE WE NEED BORDER
AGENTS FREIGHT I WAS STRUCK BY
GAVIN NEWSOM, HE HAS
PRESIDENTIAL ASPIRATIONS FOR HI
TO GO NEAR THE BORDER AND SAY W
HAVE THIS, YOU HAPPY AGAIN, HEA
ADAMS JUST TODAY SAYING THIS IS
BASICALLY NOT FAIR TO NEWARK WH
ALREADY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCE
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC MAYOR OF EL
PASO SO I DO THINK YOU ARE
STARTING TO SEE IT IS GOING TO
HAVE TO START WITH SOME OF THES
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS, MAYBE SOME
OF THIS PRESIDENTIAL AMBITIONS
MAY BE SOME WHO WANT THIS WHITE
HOUSE TO STOP WITH THIS ENTIRE
STANDARD OPERATING PROCEDURE OF
DON'T BELIEVE WHAT YOU SEE WITH
YOUR TWO EYES, BELIEVE WHAT I
SA